the nine picture deal would be Nick Fury
so my thought was well how long do I
have to stay allowed to do nine you know
[Music]
I was in the comic book store and I saw
this Ultimates coming that's like I
don't remember giving him a permission
to use my image in a comic book so I
called my agent my manager is like what
is this Ultimates thing and they were
like I don't know what are you talking
about now told him and they called
Marvel Marvel well like it says in the
comic book if we ever make a movie who
do you want to play you and Nick Fury go
samuel l.jackson in the comic book so we
gonna we do plan on making the movies
and we hope you'll be in the movies and
that was the beginning of that but you
know when I signed up on the Marvel in
the Marvel Universe and a 9 picture deal
to beat Nick Fury so I knew I was gonna
be Nick Fury 9 times my thought was well
how long do I stay allowed to do nine
movies you know so I didn't know they
were gonna do now movies in two years
[Music]
I like Elijah a lot yeah he's in the top
ten yes for sure
yeah villains villains have raised on
detrás you know good guys all they want
to do is you know save the world and
keep the bad guys and doing what he's
doing bad guys have reasons for doing
the things they want to do it's always
fun you know good guys are just rated
here save the world when we did an
unbreakable Knight told me it was a
trilogy so I guess for the next 18 years
every time I saw him it's kind of like
where's the other two movies what's
going on Knight called me to say I'm I
just done this movie called split and I
want you to watch it and tell me what
you think I was like why he's like just
watch it and then we'll talk so he set
up a screening and I had twice enough
time oh wow so what's just me he said
that means that if this movie makes
money that's part two of unbreakable and
then we'll do part two read with a
laudner I told you see Christian Bale I
don't whisper